– Tiffany Valentine was likely born sometime
in the late 1950s in New Jersey based on this line.
– We’re from Jersey.
– [Zac] …implying that both of them are.
Tiffany is the older of two girls born in
her family.
Growing up, she was close to her mother who
had a lot of sayings about relationships that
stuck with her over the years, such as, “love
is supposed to set you free”, “if a woman
spends all day slaving over a hot stove for
a man, the least he can do is the dishes”,
“you can always smell it on girls who sell
it”, “you can’t put a price on love”,
“never let a man c***block you from what
really makes you happy”, “if you love
somebody set them free” and perhaps the
one that would be most relevant to her: “once
is a blessing, twice is a curse.”
– [Chucky] Well that would explain your
sister.
– [Zac] Other than these quotes, Tiffany’s childhood
is, surprisingly, mostly never mentioned,
leaving the cause of her sadistic, homicidal
behavior up to speculation.
When you put all her mother’s quotes together,
you realize they are all kind-of salty takes
about relationships.
It makes me wonder if Tiffany’s mother left
her father and attempted to raise the girls
alone.
The Mrs. Valentinisms come up situationally
throughout the franchise, but let’s try
putting them in the correct order and building
Tiffany’s story.
“Once is a blessing, twice is a curse.”
Tiffany’s parents started off well, but
things declined when her younger sister was
born, because caring for a second child was
more stressful.
“The least he can do is the dishes.”
Tiffany’s mom becomes fed up with her father
not pulling his weight in household chores.
“You can always smell it on girls who sell
it” and “you can’t put a price on love”.
Sounds like as their relationship deteriorated,
Mr. Valentine turned to a pr*stitute.
“Never let a man c***block you from what
really makes you happy” and “if you love
somebody set them free.”
She finally snaps, and gets divorced from
Tiffany’s father.
My guess is that it was quite a dramatic falling
out, which will help to explain almost all
of Tiffany’s puzzling behavior later on.
As far we can tell, she has never had any
platonic friends.
She’s hanging out alone at a nightclub in
1984, sipping a martini when she’s first
approached by a man who calls her Red.
He’s referring to her red hair.
It’s not clear if this is her natural hair
color, but red is her favorite color.
– Is there something I can do for you?
– Yeah, maybe there is.
– [Zac] They all end up at the Hotel Hackensack,
where Tiffany and the blonde get busy while
the man watches.
She demonstrates her aggressive behavior by
ripping off the woman’s necklace.
While she’s distracted, the man yanks her
off of the bed and gestures a knife in her
direction.
Instead of cowering away, she just just smiles
and eggs him on.
– Do it.
Do it to me now.
– Her aggressiveness with the woman and
masochism with the man is enough to make me
think that Tiffany had already discovered
her bloodlust prior to meeting this couple,
and she was probably at that nightclub looking
for prey.
She was wearing a leopard pattern afterall,
she’s identifying herself as a predator.
The man locks eyes with her for a minute,
and the blonde gets jealous.
In an unexpected move, he stabs the blonde
instead of the redhead, and invites Tiffany
to play in the carnage with him.
She proceeds to stab the woman seven more
times as she breaks down into cries of joy
and laughter.
– Wow, it’s never happened like that before.
– She doesn't specify exactly what she’s
talking about here, but it does further my
suspicion that this isn’t the first chapter
of her crime career.
The two passionately make love beside the
mess they just created.
She introduces herself, and when she learns
his name, Charles, she is the one to suggest
that he go by Chucky.
He gives her a suggestion as well: to go blonde.
These suggestions each became iconic elements
of their respective characters.
And so began one of the worst, most toxic
romances I’ve ever ****ing seen.
To learn how Tiffany’s childhood shaped
her into a monster, the secrets behind her
survival, the disturbing truth about her motherhood
and how her career as a professional poker
player helped her carry out an evil plot in
the future, stick around to the end of this
video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
Welcome to Horror History.
There are not many characters who have the
power to revitalize a franchise so many years
in.
After Child’s Play 3 in 1991, producers
Don Mancini and David Kirschner were inspired
to try a fresh take for Chucky after seeing
the way Scream reinvigorated the horror genre
with satire, something they talked about on
the movie’s official website back in the
days when movie websites didn’t suck.
The fourth Chucky film became more of a romantic
comedy by introducing a love interest for
the supernaturally possessed doll.
Enter Tiffany Valentine, or as she would become
known, Tiffany Ray.
Tiffany is a name of Greek origin, meaning
“Manifestation of God”.
She would be the second character ever to
be aided by the power of the Voodoo God Damballa.
Valentine refers to the holiday of love and
romance, Valentine’s Day.
Tiffany’s entire character has been influenced
by her mother’s distorted teachings about
love.
Although the fanbase is split on the comedic
approach to Chucky, which I refer to as the
Bride-Seed arc, most would agree that Tiffany
has become a fan favorite character who stuck
around even after the movies swung back to
a horror first approach.
From an emotional standpoint, there is a lot
going on with this character, so let's take
it back to her mid 20s to understand how she
got so messed up.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Tiffany is referred to as a body disposal
expert.
It’s clear that she has no sense of morality,
but her skill when it comes to cleaning up
after herself at least keeps her from facing
any murder charges in her 20s.
That being said, her disregard for other laws
still got her in trouble, often landing her
with jail time and mugshot in the newspaper.
– I always dreamed of having a big church
wedding with bridesmaids and a cake and my
picture in the paper -- not just my usual
mugshot but something really flattering.
– At some point, authorities distinguished
her from being a common criminal and determined
that mental illness was a factor.
– Is Mommy ill?
– The courts thought so…
– She’s somehow able to stay out of an
institution.
I would conclude her life of crime linked
to mental illness was a direct result of her
upbringing.
Her mother’s philosophies make it clear
that there was a lot of friction between Tiffany’s
parents.
This medically reviewed article by Clinical
Social Worker Amy Morin describes the mental
effects that fighting parents can have on
a child.
A lot of these describe Tiffany’s behavior,
but for now, let’s look at Behavior Problems.
“Parental conflict has been linked to increased
aggression, delinquency, and conduct problems
in children.”
As these kids develop into adults, behavior
problems in school become run-ins with the
law, inability to fit in in society, and mugshots
in the paper.
Shortly after she hooked up with Chucky, Chucky
actually killed Tiffany’s mother.
The woman that Tiff is constantly quoting.
Yet, she stays with Chucky after this, and
even wants to spend more time with him.
– [Tiffany] I mean, I always wanted us to
spend more time together, maybe do some traveling
and see the world.
– This suggests that in her adulthood, she
didn’t have a good relationship with her
mother, which could likely be a lingering
effect of parental fighting.
“It can affect the parent-child relationship…
the quality of the relationship may be affected
as it may be difficult for parents to show
warmth and affection when they’re angry
and upset with the other parent.”
I can basically go on and on about how parental
quarrels may have impacted her.
For example, it can cause insecurity.
Tiffany gets a tattoo on her chest, a heart
with a dagger and her boyfriend’s name.
This study in the National Library of Medicine
found that young women with tattoos reported
significantly lower self esteem.
I’m not saying all tattoos bad -- I have
a tattoo -- but the difference is mine is
perfect, and I had a long time to think about
it.
Tiffany’s is a tacky emotional crutch she
got to impress a man who doesn’t actually
care about her.
Tiffany also becomes a big fan of Martha Stewart.
The article states that women who watch Martha
Stewart have significantly…
I’m kidding.
After a few years of dating and committing
crimes together in Hackensack it was time
for these two fish to move to a bigger pond
-- or should I say lake?
But first there was one order of business
to take care of.
(Impact)
♪ Mysterious music ♪
Before leaving New Jersey, Chucky and Tiffany
need a vehicle, and the two look at this 1960
Pontiac Perisian.
Tiffany loves the color, Coronado red, because
it’s her favorite color and it can easily
hide splatters of blood.
When the seller discloses that the previous
owners were decapitated in the car, she gets
a huge smile.
She gleefully slashes the seller’s throat
with her nail file and climbs into the driver’s seat.
She also takes a little taste of her blood.
Along with weaponizing her nail file, this
is something that becomes a signature of hers.
As they set off she notices Chucky reading
something about Voodoo, something that would
become a very big part of her life later on.
They arrive in Chicago, Illinois in 1988 and
get their first apartment together.
She’s immediately blown away by it and begins
interior designing in her head -- Martha Stewart
has been rubbing off on her.
Charles suggests they order a pizza, and she
loves the idea, because she knows exactly
what that means.
Not only are they ordering a pizza, but they’re
also ordering a pizza delivery man, and new
victims are just as satiating as deep dish
for these two.
They share a cigarette afterwards as they
debate the merits of Chicago vs Jersey style
pizza.
This scene also contains more potential evidence
that disaccord from her youth is still affecting her.
Another telltale sign is substance abuse,
something that becomes much more likely in
a high-conflict family.
But at least at this point, the young couple
is getting along.
Like substance abuse, violence seems to be
something that can numb over any relationship
issues.
I think a lot of people have had that ex that
isn’t really compatible with you, but when
you’re in bed everything is good.
For these two, it’s offing people.
And like that ex, there are a limited amount
of times you turn to this distraction before
the relationship issues are impossible to
ignore.
As they stop hunting together as frequently,
tension rises in their relationship.
At the time of the original movie, Chucky
has his own place, so my theory is that they
broke up, causing him to move out, but they
got back together, and Chucky just kept his
other apartment to use for other purposes.
Besides, he’s definitely not getting his
deposit back seeing as what he’s done with
the place.
Chucky starts seeing another woman at this
point, however, it’s not clear if Tiffany
knew about this.
I don’t think she did, but I’ll get to
that later.
On November 8th, 1988, Tiffany comes home
from the grocery store with ingredients to
make Chucky’s favorite food: Swedish meatballs,
and catches him in the other room finishing
some lady with his knife.
That’s not an innuendo, I mean that literally.
But to her, stabbing solo is just as bad as
cheating; she’s jealous that he’s getting
his fix without her.
A sort of new form of JGS that we’ve never
explored before.
She confronts him on their lack of murder
dates as of late, but he just blows off the argument.
It’s obvious that this isn’t the first
time they’ve separated without being able
to talk out the problem.
It’s a symptom of one of the biggest effects
of parental in-fighting: relationship issues.
It’s pretty obvious how this goes.
As a kid, your brain is still developing and
adapting to your environment.
When kids see their parents fighting all the
time, they learn that that’s how you solve
disputes, and they end up using the same tactics
in their personal relationships, which means:
toxic relationships.
Instead of trying to fix the issue, she tries
to get back at her boyfriend.
She calls the police station and asks for
Detective Mike Norris, the lead detective
on the Lakeshore Strangler case, and fills
him in on Charles’s whereabouts.
This leads to the police finding where he’s
kidnapped his mistress, chasing him through
Chicago, and ultimately killing him inside
a toy store.
After his death, Tiffany finds a ring on the
mantle, and believes Chucky had been planning
to propose to her.
Tiffany does know that Charles had been experimenting
with Voodoo, and keeps hope alive that he
might have been able to transfer his soul
out of his body before dying, so she continues
to wear the ring every day.
She searched for 10 years.
There are rumors and urban legends of a possessed
Good Guy doll that first appeared right after
Charles’s death in 1988, then again in 1990,
but the alleged activity always dissipates
before Tiffany can get there.
She’s forced to move to a mobile home in
Lockport, New York.
I’m guessing she moved there in 1998 or
1999 because at the time of Bride of Chucky
in Spring 1999, it sounds like she hasn’t
been around for long.
– You moving out already?
– [Zac] She keeps the ring and the car, but nothing
else.
Her belief in Chucky’s return is so strong
that she fantasizes about having a baby with
him when he comes back and builds a slide
out playpen in her trailer.
The place is decorated all over with baby
dolls.
It’s possible that she just has an obsession
with dolls because of the legends about her
boyfriend becoming a doll, but based on her
past, I have a different theory.
I talked about the emotional damage she received
from her parents fighting with each other,
but perhaps the stressful home environment
also led to one of the parents abusing her.
These victims tend to have their emotional
development stunted.
In other words, the trauma may freeze their
brain’s development, making them unable
to grow up in certain ways.
This could explain the baby dolls, the “little
girl” voice associated with many of these
types of victims…
– Awake!
Awake!
Awake, awake, awake!
– …childlike tantrums, and many other
symptoms, some of which overlap with psychological
damage caused by fighting between parents.
I’m not gonna dwell on this too much, because
there’s no evidence that she was abused…
it’s possible that she just likes dolls…
but I wouldn’t be surprised if we end up
learning her parents were a little heavy handed
with her.
It seems like she’s about to move on from
Chucky by 1999.
She starts dating a cringy goth dude named
Damian, but doesn’t put out for him, because
in her words:
– I’ll kill anyone, but I’ll only sleep
with someone I love.
– And she doesn’t love him because he’s
not a real killer like Chucky.
In 1999, she hears about another potential
Chucky appearance at a military academy in
Missouri.
The remains of the Good Guy doll end up in
an evidence locker nearby, so she bribes a
cop named Robert Bailey to retrieve them for
her, only to slit his throat with her nail
file and collect the spoils.
She goes home to sew the doll back together
and attempts to bring it to life with the
help of her Voodoo For Dummies book.
It doesn’t appear to work at first, however,
Damian comes over and she soon notices that
the doll has moved.
She gets the idea to chain Damian to the bed
and strip-tease for both him and the doll.
– If anyone even looked at me, Chucky would
take care of him.
Wouldn’t you Chucky?
– This is her cue.
Chucky turns his head to lock eyes with Damian
and Tiffany looks on as her ex rips out her
new boyfriend’s piercing and smothers him
with a pillow.
Bringing someone to an early grave is what
started Tiffany and Chucky’s relationship,
and it also provides the spark for them to
rekindle that relationship here.
The couple are actually glad to see each other
for a couple of minutes before they go back
to being toxic as ****. It’s part of a long
cycle, which we will see more examples of.
It doesn’t take long for the friction between
them to start up again when Chucky makes an
off putting comment.
– I always thought you were gonna let yourself
go.
– Nonetheless, she prepares him his favorite
meal, Swedish Meatballs, and explains how
she never stopped wearing his ring.
She is dismayed to find out that Charles had
stolen the ring in order to sell it, not to
propose to her.
When he hysterically laughs in his face, she
realizes that he hasn’t changed and probably
never will.
She locks him in her makeshift playpen, and
tells him she prefers him in this baby-like
form.
I think what she really likes is having control
over him, since his independent behavior is
what caused issues for them in the past.
The bedroom is one thing, but hopefully I
don’t have to explain why it’s not a good
idea to get involved with a woman who is a
control freak in ALL aspects of life.
This is another aspect of her character that
stays with her through the years.
That night she removes her ring for the first
time and weeps in her bed next to Damian’s
lifeless body.
The next day, she would look for love elsewhere,
but her search, and her life… would be cut
short.
(impact)
♪ mysterious music ♪
The next day, Tiffany gets her neighbor, Jesse
Miller, to help her load the trunk containing
Damain’s body into the car.
She asks Jesse out on a date evening, but
Jesse has a girlfriend, so Tiffany tells him
to treat her right, and heads off to dump
Damian in the East River, which according
to Buffalo native and fellow YouTube creator
Bryce Edward Brown, is the prime location
to dump bodies in New York… not sure why
he knows that.
On the way back, she buys a female doll, about
Chucky’s size, and puts it into the playpen
with him to be his new partner to taunt him.
That evening she takes a bath and giggles
as she watches the news report on her most
recent string of victims before switching
to Bride of Frankenstein, which she seems
moved by, perhaps because of the monster’s
unconditional interest in the Bride upon their meeting.
While Tiffany is distracted, Chucky escapes
his cage and pushes her TV into the bath,
causing her to be electrocuted to death.
This is where most people do that joke where
the video is over, but I’m kinda sick of
that meme, so let’s just skip to the part
where Chucky transfers her soul into the female
doll and she wakes up, realizes what happened,
and is horrified.
With both of them in doll form, Chucky wants
to marry her so that she can love, serve,
and obey him.
Hopefully I don’t have to explain why it’s
not a good idea to get involved with someone
with those intentions.
Tiffany is more interested in transferring
back into a human body, but Chuck explains
to do that they will need an amulet called
The Heart of Damballa, which was buried with
Chucky’s human corpse in Hackensack, NJ.
They come up with a plan to get Jesse to drive
them to the cemetery in Hackensack for $1000
under the ruse that Tiffany can’t deliver
the dolls herself because she’s taking care
of a friend who is mentally incapacitated.
(slurping sound)
Before leaving, she gives herself a makeover
to look more like her human self, which I
don’t get because she’s planning to go
back to a human form in just a couple days.
– Women.
– Next, there’s a scene that isn’t shown
in any movie, but is kind of important to
talk about.
Chucky and Tiffany hide Tiffany’s discarded
human body somewhere, so that Jesse doesn’t
come into the trailer and discover it rotting
there.
This works to their advantage much later on,
but we’ll get to that.
After finding Tiffany’s note, Jesse makes
an unexpected stop to pick up his girlfriend,
Jade, with plans to run away and get married,
which Tiffany finds romantic, but Chucky finds
sickening.
– That’s so romantic!
– I’d give ‘em six months.
Three if she gains weight.
– [Zac] They watch as Jade’s uncle, the Lockport
police chief Warren Kincaid, tries to plant
drugs in Jesse’s van, so Tiffany creates
a trap using nails and an airbag, designed
to kill Warren when he goes to investigate
her giggling in the front seat.
They hide the chief under the back seat before
Jesse and Jade get back.
They must be able to hoist him up there due
to the super strength afforded by Damballa.
When Jesse and Jade come back, they stay in
“barbie mode” around humans to try to
get to their destination without raising suspicion.
The van immediately gets pulled over by another
cop, the chief’s lackey, Officer Norton.
As he searches the vehicle, Tiffany kicks
him in the head to prevent him from finding
Warren’s body, but as a result, he does
find the drugs that were planted there.
Wanting to keep their journey on track, and
their chauffeur out of prison, Chucky borrows
Tiff’s lighter, and she watches with delight
as he uses it to ignite Officer Norton’s
gas tank.
(scream, explosion)
Jesse speeds away from the scene, which Tiffany
refers to as Chucky “still knowing how to
show a girl a good time.”
Once again, all logic about the compatibility
of their relationship goes out the window
for her when she sees Chucky do what he does
best.
The two dolls giggle as Jesse and Jade bicker
about what just actually happened.
They stop at a small chapel in Niagara Falls
to tie the knot, and Tiffany shares her longtime
dream of getting married, which actually causes
Chucky to stop and actually give her a real apology.
I guess being back on the run from the law
with her reminded him of their younger days
and struck a chord with him.
Every time blood spills, they seem to get
a little bit closer.
To add to the romance, Warren, who is somehow
still alive, pops up in the back of the van
and Chucky stabs him in the back to finish
the job.
That night, they all stay at the Honeymoon
Sweets motel in Niagara where another couple
barges into Jesse and Jade’s room, and Tiffany
notices the woman steals Jesse’s wallet.
Obviously this woman doesn’t know that the
dolls are alive, so Tiffany ends up being
the only one to see this happen, and it enrages
her.
I’m guessing Tiffany is not suddenly taking
some kind of moral high ground, and this is
more about trying to ensure that their journey
is not interrupted again.
She sneaks into their room and hurls their
champagne bottle at the mirror on the ceiling,
causing it to shatter and slice them apart
on the way down; the first example of Tiffany’s
very impressive throwing arm.
Chucky is absolutely smitten after seeing
this.
– I love you.
– He steals the ring finger of the newly
deceased newlywed and uses it to propose to
Tiffany for real this time, and she’s brought
to tears.
From this point, she goes by Tiffany Ray.
After realizing she has one human bodily function,
her tears, two two decide to test another.
Chucky believes that he doesn’t need to
use a rubber because he’s ALL rubber…
despite actually being made of plastic…
so the two brush it off and continue their
intimate moment.
This moment would have dire consequences.
Tiffany becomes pregnant, and because the
two dolls are being kept alive by the power
of Voodoo, this is a Voodoo pregnancy, which
means everything is accelerated and only takes
a couple days until delivery.
Despite that, they don’t realize they’ve
just conceived a child.
Later that night, they come up with a plan
to transfer their souls into Jesse and Jade’s
bodies once they’ve re-acquired the amulet.
The next morning, they have to make a quick
exit when the maid discovers the bodies of
the other hooneymooning couple, and Jesse
and Jade are surprised by the appearance of
their friend David, who shows up to help out
with the newfound relationship issues being
caused by the murderous dolls that they’re
towing.
When David accidentally finds Warren’s decomposing
remains in the back, he grabs the chief’s
gun and demands they pull over, just as a
passing cop recognizes Jesse’s van and approaches.
The change in circumstances forces Chucky
and Tiffany to make themselves known by pulling
out guns of their own… which I have no idea
how they obtained… and take the three humans
hostage.
This frightens David, so much that he backs
himself into oncoming traffic, so Tiffany
gives Jesse the order to
– Get this heap of **** moving!
– After getting away, they steal an RV from
an older couple by shooting them in the head
so they won’t be recognized on the road.
Tiffany ties up Jade and gives her a makeover,
presumably preparing for the moment she “moves
in” to Jade’s body.
She also makes some meatballs and cookies
in the oven for her new husband, but quickly
becomes enraged when Chucky makes a comment
about the dishes not being cleaned.
Jade and Jesse make a couple strategic remarks
to kind of turn Tiffany and Chucky against
each other.
Jade edges Tiffany to retaliate after feeling
unappreciated, and this starts a huge fight,
which includes dish throwing, bickering, and
insulting Chucky’s manhood.
– Take it from me honey, plastic is no substitute
for a nice hunk of wood.
– Jade uses the distraction to kick Tiffany
into the oven, and the RV crashes in the ensuing
chaos, conveniently right into the cemetery
where they need to go.
Tiffany’s skin bakes inside of the oven,
increasing her rage even further.
She busts out and attacks Jade, biting her
in the ear, before Jesse grabs her and throws
her out the window.
She’s unable to get to her gun before Jesse,
and he takes her as a hostage to counter Chucky,
who is holding Jade at gunpoint.
They come to the grave plot of Charles Lee
Ray, where the exhumation is currently in
progress.
When Jesse and Tiffany get there, Chucky has
recovered the amulet.
The two make an exchange: Jade will go back
to Jesse in exchange for Chucky getting Tiffany
back, but something is different about her
demeanor this time, she’s really had it
with Chucky.
We see the difference in how Jesse and Chucky
treat their women.
Jade falls into Jesse’s arms, but Chucky
lets Tiffany fall to the ground.
This allows Tiffany to see how she wants to
be treated vs. how she’s actually treated
in real time, and for her, this is the final
straw.
– Endonline pour de boisette damballa!
Endelieu pour de boisette damballa!!!
(impact)
♪ melancholic music ♪
– Jesse and Jade find themselves tied up
by Chucky, who attempts to perform the Damballa
chant to possess their bodies.
Before completing the ritual, Tiffany tells
Chucky that she loves him and that they belong
together forever, but while kissing him, she
steals his knife and uses it to stab him in
the back before clarifying: they do belong
together, they belong together in hell.
The two fight, and Chucky stabs her in the
chest, but she at least creates enough of
a distraction for Jesse to knock Chuck down
into the open grave, where he’s ultimately
killed once more.
After the dust settled, the lead detective
on the Jesse and Jade case discovered Tiffany’s
charred remains, and she springs to life with
the very last of her energy to give birth
to a child before she gives out; in a way,
fulfilling her mother’s prophecy that love
would set her free.
It’s not known exactly how, but Chucky and
Tiffany’s doll bodies end up in the hands
of a movie studio, rather than in another
evidence locker.
Tiffany’s human body is still never discovered.
She remains dead for another 5 years, until
March 18th 2004.
The dolls have been adapted into animatronics,
which are being used to shoot a movie called
Chucky Goes Psycho, in which Tiffany helps
Chucky defeat a man pretending to be Santa
Claus.
During a break, they are sitting in a prop
room when their child, who has since been
given the name Sh*tface, finally tracks them
down and reads the inscription found on the
back of the Heart of Damballa, which brings
both Chucky and Tiffany to life with a jolt
of electricity.
Tiffany’s motherly instincts immediately
kick in, and she asks where his parents are
before realizing who he really is.
As the two embrace, she calls him Sweetface,
the same name she had given to Jesse when
she was hitting on him.
Maybe this is not that big of a deal, but
I do find it a little off-putting that she
time and time again shows no separation between
romantic love and motherly love.
We see it again much later, when she reunites
with doll Chucky, aka, her husband, and treats
him like a little baby, but we’ve got a
lot to cover before we can even begin to unpack
that.
And I’m not saying it’s weird for couples
to use pet names, a lot of people do that…
although it is CRINGE… but it’s more the
way that Tiffany does it in addition to her
other pre-existing derangements that makes
me feel this is just another example of Tiffany’s
poorly adjusted behavior.
Before Sweetface can finish filling them in
on where they are, the animatronic effects
artist comes in and goes to work on Tiffany,
but gets a shock upon opening her up to find
real human organs.
Chucky tosses a length of string around the
man’s neck and Tiffany helps do the honors
of decapitating him with it.
Once again, this act overwhelms the two of
them with passion, and all past drama is forgotten
as they share a kiss… which is interrupted
by the sound of their kid, pissing his or
her pants.
Come to think of it, they never did get around
to the whole gender reveal party, considering
they were both killed right as he was born,
so when they go to check things out for themselves,
the kid has no genitals, just what you would
expect from a children’s doll.
Tiffany wants her child to be a girl, while
Chucky wants a son.
Chucky names the kid Glen, and Tiffany goes
with Glenda.
The nomenclature was inspired by the 1953
drama film, Glen or Glenda.
I’m just gonna go with Glen for now to make
things easier.
This gender disagreement would be the source
of a lot of confusion for the child later
on, but before arguing any further, they’re
interrupted by Hollywood actress Jennifer
Tilly, who is using the room as a secret snacking
location.
Tiffany is starstruck upon seeing her idol,
perhaps Ms. Tilly was an inspiration to her
because she looks and sounds just like Tiffany
did when she had a human body.
Jennifer Tilly soon after realizes that the
decapitated head on the ground is no movie
prop, and the movie shuts down to let the
crime scene procedures begin.
The frenzy of paparazzi provides a distraction
for Tiffany and her boys to sneak out and
stow themselves away in Jennifer Tilly’s
limo.
Tiffany is dazzled by the sight of the Hollywood
sunset, and it seems to inspire her to develop
a new plan to be apart of that SoCal stardom
by transferring her soul into Jennifer Tilly’s
body and for Chucky to take over the body
of rapper / movie producer Redman so that
they can be the most powerful couple in Hollywood,
or something.
However, that leaves Glen still needing a
body, and Tiffany doesn’t want to get pregnant
again, so she plans to knock up Jennifer before
performing the soul transfer ritual, using
her as what she calls a “surrogate mother”,
and what the rest of us call “human trafficking”.
I think sometimes Tiffany likes to recontextualize
the horrible things she does to distract her
from how horrible they are, like earlier on,
when she refers to her killing sprees with
Chucky as “dates”.
As they put their child to sleep that evening,
he asks a question they are not prepared for.
– Why do you kill people?
– [Zac] Chucky wants his kid to grow up to become
a killer, but Tiffany thinks they should set
a good example now that they’re parents
and she nags Chucky until he reluctantly agrees
to stop killing, mostly to shut her up.
Later that night, Tiffany sends Chucky into
the bathroom with a cup to start the artificial
insemination process, and later knocks Redman
out with Ms. Tilly’s Most Improved Actress
Award.
She confronts, and scolds Jennifer on her
lack of self-respect for trying to sleep her
way into a role, then immediately changes
tones and asks her hero for an autograph,
which of course, freaks Jennifer the f***
out.
Maybe that was part of the plan.
Jennifer just runs for it, so Tiffany once
again displays her impressive cannon of an
arm and nails her in the back of the head
with the trophy.
The two dolls drag the unconscious movie stars
to bed.
Once again, we see the added strength that
the magic of Damballa gives to help them move
these bodies, but even still…
– [Tiffany] F*** she’s fat.
I can’t believe it.
She’s not even pregnant yet.
– Tiffany is the one to… uhh… decorate
the cake.
The next morning is March 19th, and Tiffany’s
plan works; because Jennifer wakes up thinking
her battle with the 3 foot plastic superfan
was all a dream.
Meanwhile, Tiff reads up on kicking her addiction
to committing homicide.
She kind of skims through the first 8 steps,
but the ninth tells her to make amends with
anyone she may have harmed, so she starts
by calling up Ruth Bailey, the widow of the
police officer she killed five years earlier.
Her apology confuses and distresses Ms. Bailey,
but Jennifer seems oblivious, which I see
as another coping mechanism to help her ignore
how harmful her actions really are.
In the evening, Jennifer tells Redman she’s
pregnant.
Again, the signs show up much faster than
usual because the father is being kept alive
by Voodoo, thus making it a Voodoo pregnancy.
Redman informs her that he got a vasectomy
so he can’t be the father, and adds that
she can no longer be in his movie because
in his words,
– She gotz to be… hot.
– Tiffany overhears their conversation through
the vent and is outraged, and tempted to kill
Redman herself, but she resists the urge,
and calls up a support hotline instead.
The guy she talks to is very unhelpful though,
and almost encourages her, by saying that
having a slip up is OK because “Rome wasn’t
built in a day.”
It’s unclear if this is a support hotline
specifically for serial killers, or just a
hotline for addicts of all types.
At first I thought it was a line for all types
of addicts, which would explain why he doesn’t
make a huge deal out of her having a slip
up, but then again I’m not sure what he’s
talking about with this line:
– [Man on Phone] Yeah, and believe me, it was not pretty.
In fact it took me three hours just to clean
up the mess.
– I guess he could be talking about a mess
he made while he was drunk or something, but
it almost sounds like it is actually a serial
killer hotline.
Regardless, his advice encourages Tiffany
to invite herself to dinner with Redman that evening.
(fleshy sound)
Glen notices his mother cutting out Redman’s
intestines, and Tiffany is embarrassed to
have broken her vow in front of him, an event
that he doesn’t really know how to process.
The next morning, March 20th, Chucky and Tiffany
watch the execution of Martha Stewart in bed
when they hear Jennifer’s horrified reaction
at her now very visible pregnancy.
Jennifer calls her assistant to vent about
the scary new development, and Tiffany joins
in on the call to confuse and torture them,
since her voice is identical to Jennifer's.
She finds Chucky tying Jennifer to the bed,
and he accidentally drops a photo of him and
Glen killing the paparazzi.
This sets her off because of their agreement
not to kill anymore to set a good example
for their child.
A huge argument ensues, and it's not long
before they're back on their disagreement
of if they should raise a girl or boy.
There's a lot of irony here.
After all of her fuss to try to create a good
environment to raise a child by shielding
him or her from violence, she ends up putting
him or her in the very same kind of environment
she likely grew up in, a household with two
parents who are constantly fighting.
Glen states he or she cannot decide what he
or she wants to be, but knows that he or she
is not a killer and Tiffany says that this
makes her proud.
Chucky finds Redman’s body hidden in a wardrobe,
so she’s gotta call in a new male body for
Chucky to transfer into, which would be Jennifer’s
limo driver, Stan.
– [Tiffany on Phone] Stan, baby, I need your body.
– I'll be right there.
– Simp!
It’s not really clear to me why they still
couldn’t just use Redman, as being alive
has never been a prerequisite for possessing
a body before.
How else would they have gotten into doll
bodies in the first place?
When Stan arrives, they take him prisoner
as well, and Tiffany thinks they’re a cute
couple, as she did with Jesse and Jade.
Her mother’s teachings seem to have imparted
this idealized version of love that her toxicity
prevents her from actually achieving.
The vitriol between Chucky and Tiffany continues
to build as they prepare for the birth of
the baby, and subsequently, the three soul
transfer rituals.
(impact)
♪ upbeat music ♪
With Chucky’s call upon the Voodoo powers
of Damballa looming, an interruption arises
in the form of Jennifer Tilly’s concerned
personal assistant.
Chucky finds a hiding spot so that he can
surprise and take care of her, while Tiffany
steps out of the room to grab a drink.
When she comes back, she’s faced with a
very different situation.
Glen has now changed his identity and appearance
to Glenda, in order to murder Jen’s assistant
with a makeshift flamethrower.
(glass shatters) – What did I miss?
– Tiffany is taken aback by this psychotic
new behavior, even if she did get what she
wanted by Glen choosing the female identity.
She slaps Glenda in the face, telling her
to wake up, and this seems to revert her back
into being Glen.
Essentially, there are two identities living
in one body.
If you’ve seen Psycho, it helped inspire
this concept, which I talk more about in the
Things You Missed episode on Seed of Chucky.
Before they have time to really sort this
out, it’s time to deliver the baby, and
Tiffany serves as the midwife.
– It’s a boy!
– Yes, we can tell by the blue blanket that
you somehow have.
However, to Tiffany’s surprise, there’s
also a second twin, this one a girl.
With three human bodies collected, plus one
extra, it’s time to perform the Voodoo ritual.
Tiffany interrupts to allow Glenda the opportunity
to choose which twin she wants to inhabit,
but realizes that since they have the amulet,
this choice doesn’t have to be permanent.
The cops show up, so she rushes Chucky along
to perform the ritual, and with everyone screaming
at him he snaps and backs out of the whole
thing.
She’s unwilling to change her course,
she has seen the opportunity for Hollywood
stardom, and she chooses that life over an
eternity as a doll and breaks up with Chucky.
– It’s over…
– There’s just one problem.
You don’t break up with the Chuck.
He attempts to throw the knife at her, but
she’s saved by Stan breaking free at just
the right time… or from his point of view,
just the wrong time.
She throws the blade back at her now ex-doll,
but with the police just outside, and on their
way upstairs, all three toys have to duck
out.
Tiffany and Glen are able to hitch a ride
with the ambulance and sneak into the hospital
room where Jennifer Tilly is being tended
to.
They hide under the bed and listen in on the
latest information: the police have somehow
cleared her of being the killer, despite being
the only witness of the FX guy’s death,
Redman’s death, her limo driver’s death,
her assistant’s death, and three other people
found dead in her home, which makes no sense,
but the police aren’t convinced she’s
mentally competent and might not let her see
her newborn children.
Tiffany injects something into her IV, which
causes her to pass out and once again tries
to proceed with the soul transfer ritual.
– [Tiffany] And switch!
Switch!
Switch, switch switch!
– Like her initial spell to try to reawaken
Chucky, there’s something about how Tiffany
performs the ritual that causes the effects
to be delayed, and this allows Chucky time
to get inside and lodge an ax into her head.
With her dying words, she tells Glen to be
a good girl, or boy, and not to make the same
mistakes she and Chucky did.
– Especially your dad.
– But these aren’t really her last words,
obviously.
As you can see there is more time left in
the video.
The soul transfer takes effect and she rolls
over, now in Jennifer's Body.
Not you.
Jennifer Tilly’s body.
But seeing his mother get chopped up awakens
something inside of Glen and he goes ninja
mode.
Tiff slides him the ax and he uses it to finish
Chucky once and for… well… once.
After the deed is done, she tries to console
her son, who is surely full of confusing emotions
at this point.
We can assume they next took the amulet to
the nursery to transfer Glen and Glenda into
their human bodies.
When the ritual was performed, they really
did switch places.
At first it appeared that Jennifer Tilly switched
into the doll body, then died immediately,
but apparently she actually survived, and
Tiffany held onto the doll to use Jennifer
to her advantage.
She put her to work, forcing her to do her
taxes, play online poker and even do voice
over work as Bonnie on Family Guy.
And all this so Tiffany could live the life
of luxury for years to come!
Tiffany took over Jennifer Tilly's life; but
she was really worried that Jennifer's close
relatives would notice something was off about
her behavior.
So, to avoid any suspicion, she cut off contact
with them.
Tiffany didn't want the twins to feel lonely
and without a sense of extended family, so
she started organizing regular get-togethers
with Jennifer's actor friends.
The get-togethers included Bound co-stars
Gina Gershon, Sutton Stracke, and Joe Pantoliano,
and they became like the twins' aunts and
uncles!
Around this time, it’s likely that the movie,
The Seed Of Chucky, went into production as
Jennifer Tilly has a Seed of Chucky Poster
in her home.
I’ll also note that Jennifer Tilly was credited
for being in Bride of Chucky, but I assume
that came out before Tiffany took over.
The release dates of these movies in the Chucky universe obviously doesn't align with the release dates in our world.
All of this happens before the twins' 5th
birthday, on March 20th 2009.
Tiffany has assumed the life of Jennifer Tilly,
so she’s holding a big party at her Hollywood
Hills mansion.
As a single mother, she has hired a new nanny
named, Fulvia, to help look after the kids,
who loves Glen, but literally fears Glenda.
Tiffany uses the doll to beat down Fulvia
in an act of revenge for her disloyalty.
At the time, it appeared to be just an object,
not moving and not alive.
It’s possible that this was Jennifer though, holding
entirely still.
Or maybe she just acquired multiple wedding
Belle dolls during this time.
She once again writes this off as a little
slip, so she’s continuing to use “Rome
wasn’t built in a day” as an excuse to
continue her killing career.
It seems she has an understanding with Glenda,
the murderous of the two kids, to keep all
this quiet, maintaining the illusion of a
perfect family for Glen, which is what he
wants more than anything.
She likely continued living as a Hollywood
movie star and poorly parenting her kids through
the turn of the decade.
At some point, she went back across the country
to retrieve her car, which was left outside
her old trailer in Lockport, New York.
Glen and Glenda would be eight years old at
the beginning of 2013, when Chucky next pops up.
We don’t know if there was an event that
caused Tiff to get back together with him,
yet again, after their dramatic breakup nearly
a decade before.
All we know is that Chucky somehow shows up
at the front door of the woman he was seeing
in 1988 right before he got killed, Sarah
Pierce.
It’s possible that somebody helped pack
and mail Chucky to Sarah's doorstep, but if
that is the case, I don’t think it was Tiffany
that helped him, because as I alluded to earlier,
I don't think Tiffany ever knew about Sarah,
and Chucky wouldn't want to put himself in
a situation where Tiffany starts asking questions
about who this woman actually is.
There's no way she would help him once she
found out.
Chucky doesn’t necessarily need Tiffany’s
help to package and mail himself.
For example, in Child’s Play 3, he mails
himself to the military academy despite not
having connected with her yet.
We can only assume he tricks someone else
into helping him, or somehow does it himself,
it’s not really explained.
Anyways, after arriving in Rhode Island, Chucky
massacres the Pierce family and the only survivors
are Sarah’s daughter, Nica Pierce, and granddaughter,
Alice Pierce.
There’s a very public trial in April 2013,
where the Chucky doll is used as a key piece
of evidence as Nica is blamed for the murders
and ruled to be insane.
Tiffany probably heard about this in the news,
realized Chucky was back and started to fall
for him again because she can’t resist a
killer.
It's an inescapable cycle for her.
On April 6th or 7th, the day that Nica’s
trial ended, she pulls out an old trick by
bribing a police officer to bring her the
evidence -- aka: the Chucky doll -- before
grabbing him from behind and slashing his
throat, the same thing she did to Robert Bailey
14 years before.
Presumably, Chucky and Tiffany rekindle their
relationship and Tiffany agrees to help with
his plan by mailing him to his next destination,
where Chucky tricks Alice into letting him
perform the chant to take over her body.
After doing so, Tiffany goes through the adoption
process to become Alice’s legal guardian,
using the name Tiffany Valentine.
Important note: she does not sign the adoption
paperwork as the movie star: Jennifer Tilly.
– Did anyone ever tell you you look exactly
like Jennifer Tilly?
– Yeah, I get that a lot.
– Remember when I said that Chucky and Tiffany
hiding Tiffany’s original human body would
be important later?
This is why.
Tiffany is an expert at disposing of human
remains, so nobody ever finds her original corpe.
This allows her to be Jennifer in her day
to day life, but also be Tiffany whenever
it’s convenient for her.
If Jennifer had tried to adopt Alice, there
would have been a huge spotlight on her, and
if something were to happen to Alice, it wouldn’t
look good, considering that Ms. Tilly was
the sole witness of 6 murders that took place
in her house in 2004.
But since Tiffany is the one adopting the
child, people aren’t really gonna be paying attention.
This also goes back to what I said earlier
about Tiffany not distinguishing romantic
love from motherly love.
From the outside, it’s a random woman taking
in an orphaned little girl, but from her point
of view, she’s adopting her lover, which
is weird.
After Alice’s usefulness eventually runs
its course, she is allegedly killed, something
that Tiffany later expresses regret for.
Even here, she can’t fully suppress her
motherly instincts.
I’m assuming Tiffany was also the person
to mail one duplicate Chucky to Andy Barclay’s
apartment six months later on November 8th
2013, though, it didn't end well for him.
– Andy?
(gunshot)
– This doesn’t really matter though, because
by this time, Chucky has discovered a new
spell on Voodoo for Dummies.com that allows
him to split his soul into multiple different bodies.
Tiffany would also find uses for this spell,
and Chucky and Tiffany’s relationship would
get a whole lot more interesting.
(impact)
♪ eerie music ♪
By the year 2017, Tiffany and Chucky are somehow
still on good terms.
Or at least they’re back on good terms.
Who knows how many times they broke up from
2013-2017.
Chucky’s new plan is to create an entire
army of Chucky dolls using the new VoodooForDummies.com spell.
It seems there’s a limit to how many times
he can replicate his soul individually, but
if he can get an innocent to kill for him,
he can automatically possess a massive number
of dolls.
Tiffany is in on this plan.
She does her part by visiting the psychiatric
hospital where Nica Pierce is being held in
captivity on January 23rd.
When Nica enters the room, Tiffany can be
seen sharpening her deadly nail file, and
she’s all dressed up in red, her favorite
color.
Guess goth was just a phase.
In this scene she’s playing the role of
Alice's mother, Tiffany Valentine.
As far as the public record is concerned,
this woman has never been married, so she
doesn’t go by Tiffany Ray when using this
identity.
From the get-go, the two don’t get along,
and Tiffany casually drops that Alice is dead,
which devastates Nica.
She fakes a few tears of her own and says
that she suspects Alice’s death was due
to a broken heart.
Essentially, she wants Nica to feel like she’s
responsible.
But messing with Nica was just a bonus.
The real purpose of the trip was to smuggle
a new Chucky doll into the mental hospital.
– [Dr Foley] That’s not the same--
– [Tiffany] No, no, this is a doll that they used
in Alice’s therapy.
To help her get over the past.
She thought that maybe, it would help you
too.
– With her mission accomplished, she leaves.
Two days later, on January 25th, she gives
Andy Barclay a call and introduces herself as
– Tiffany?
Jennifer?
Even I lose track.
– Which means she has probably been freely
switching between the two quite a lot.
I guess nobody noticed that Tiffany got her
tattoo removed.
Andy says he knows who she is and he’s coming
for her and Chucky, which she responds to
by informing him that there are three of them
at the moment: Chucky, Tiffany and a second Chucky.
She invites Andy to join the cult, which he
refuses, so she delivers a message from Chucky:
– It’s just a single word: disembowel.
– Chucky continues to carry out his plan
by inhabiting multiple dolls inside Harrogate
Hospital.
The only other thing Tiffany does at that
time is split her own soul into another body.
Remember how I said she got a second wedding Belle doll?
It’s a good insurance policy to have a backup
in case either of them gets killed.
When the time comes to get out of Harrogate,
Tiffany essentially plays the role of getaway
driver, which may have brought them closer
together, because she was there for him where
his old driver, Eddie Caputo, was not.
I mean…
He wouldn’t have been on the run in 1988
in the first place if it wasn’t for Tiffany,
but it’s a nice gesture nonetheless.
OK, not really, they’re both ****ing cancer.
Chucky walks out after possessing the body
of Nica, and Tiffany is just happy to have
her man back in a human body, it didn’t
matter that it was a woman’s body this time
-- we saw very early on in her history that
she’s a bisexual.
Like that first encounter, they make out next
to dead body, in this case, the Harrogate
Hospital security guard.
I hope they didn’t do this kind of stuff
when Chucky possessed Alice.
If you’re like me, you’ve probably wondered
at some point during this story how law enforcement
can be so totally imcompetent.
Charles Lee Ray was a well known serial killer
in the 80s.
Tiffany had many of her own run-ins with the
law during that time.
Surely someone saw them together.
Surely, someone noticed that her disappearance
in 1999 coincided with the appearance of Charles
Lee Ray’s fingerprints at many new crime
scenes.
Surely eyebrows were raised when Tiffany Valentine
reappeared out of nowhere to adopt the last
remaining family member of Charles Lee Ray’s
late mistress.
Well it seems that at some point between 2017
and 2021, investigators finally connected
those dots, and Tiffany Valentine is identified
as a “known accomplice” to Charles Lee Ray.
This information goes public on the internet.
She’s no longer able to use that identity,
so she continues going by Jennifer Tilly in
public, and Tiffany Ray around Chucky.
My theory is that Andy was the one to point
police to the fact that Charles and Tiffany
are affiliated, because when she talks to
him on the phone in Cult, he tells her, “I
know who you are.”
In March 2021, Glen and Glenda turn 17, so
Tiffany can go away on trips more often and
not have to worry as much about them as much.
At some point, she takes Chucky back to Hackensack
to revisit the early parts of their relationship.
Since there are multiple Chuckys now, I’ll
refer to this version as Nica-Chucky.
Nica occasionally takes the driver’s seat,
which Tiffany kind of likes, but pretends
not to notice, for now.
– Sometimes when we’re together I see
you looking at me.
And I know it’s you.
It’s not Chucky, it’s you, and I live
for those moments.
– If you thought it was not possible for
Chucky and Tiffany’s relationship to get
any more weird and toxic, think again!
Despite this, she continues helping Chucky
with his masterplan to terrorize America with
an army of Chucky dolls.
To do this, she meets with Hackensack’s
mayor, Michelle Cross to propose a benefit
screening and auction.
The proceeds of the screening are supposed
to fund Better Days Childrens’ Hospitals,
with the dolls being sent to sick kids across
the US.
Each one is a vintage Good Guy doll from Jennifer’s
personal collection.
If the plan works as they hope, each of these
72 dolls will be possessed with Charles Lee
Ray’s soul.
Although her feelings for Chucky are mixed,
Tiffany could never pass up an opportunity
like this to spread mayhem, and from Mayor
Cross’s point of view, it’s a good PR
stunt to promote her re-election, a distraction
from the fact that the death toll in her city
has been on the rise.
The charity event is scheduled for Mid November.
On November 8th, 2021, Chucky and Tiffany
are back in the hotel room where they first
made love, this time with a new prisoner,
and the old arguments start up again, this
time about Jennifer’s weight, which has
basically been on a steady incline.
The next day, she cuts their guest up into
smaller pieces to try to pack him into a suitcase,
and her inability to do so, combined with
Chucky’s unwillingness to help, leads to
more fighting, causing her to storm off yet
again.
It’s basically the same fight about the
dishes, still going on over two decades later.
In mid November, Tiff puts her Monsters Inc
residuals to good use and buys Charles Lee
Ray’s childhood home in Hackensack to use
as a base of operations for their ever expanding cult.
Before the deal closes, she sits around with
Chucky in their hotel playing poker -- a reference
to the real life Jennifer Tilly’s side career
as a professional poker player -- when she
notices that Nica has covertly taken the driver’s
seat.
It is probably her poker skills that allow
her to easily detect when control switches
from Chucky to Nica.
In a 2007 appearance on The Late Late Show
with Craig Ferguson, she discusses how she
worked with a celebrity profiler to learn
how to read her opponents’ body language,
so she probably picked up on the subtle differences
in behavior between Chucky and Nica.
Nica is disabled from the waist down, but
only when she has the wheel.
When Chucky is in control, he can use Nica’s
legs freely.
To test her theory, Tiffany sticks a knife
into Nica’s leg, and as expected, gets no
reaction.
Before revealing that she knows it’s Nica,
she plays along and tests her a bit, learning
that Nica drinks less beer, bites her nails,
and takes bigger risks, at least in poker.
She’s able to trick Nica into revealing
her true self, because Tiffany has a great
poker face.
She’s not only bluffing in the card game,
but also in their conversation.
Jennifer Tilly won her first professional
poker tournament in 2005, which works well
with her timeline.
In the Chucky universe, this is one year after
Tiffany possessed her body, so we can assume
that it was actually Tiffany who made her
great at poker.
Eventually, Tiffany reveals that she knows
it’s Nica -- and gets choked up as she explains
that she actually prefers being with Nica.
– I live for those moments.
– She claims that she actually bought the
Sherwood Lane house to share with Nica, not
Chucky, but honestly, I don’t know that
she’s even telling the truth about that,
because she’s kind of unraveling at this
point.
Or at least…
unraveling more than usual.
She says she wants to find a way to keep Nica
in the driver’s seat, instead of that rat
Chucky, but then she proceeds to randomly
knock Nica out with a frying pan.
I think she’s conflicted about what she
wants.
I know this is a character analysis video,
but she’s become so unhinged from the constant
opening and closing the door on her relationship
with Chucky, that it almost doesn’t make
sense to try to make sense of her at this
stage.
If I had to take a stab at it though, no pun
intended, it seems like she wants to help
raise Chucky’s army because she likes spreading
terror, but she’s leaning towards Nica from
a relationship standpoint.
After picking up the keys to her new house,
she ties Nica to a chair in the living room,
and leaves her with a kiss before heading
out.
We don’t know exactly where she goes, but
my assumption is that she’s meeting with
Mayor Cross to make sure they’re still on
for benefit screening, which would serve as
a positive distraction from the recent set
of murders that have plagued the town over
the last month or so, which of course, were
caused by Chucky, who is still trying to convince
an innocent soul to kill as part of his ritual.
Tiffany’s next move is to help Chucky move
this along, this time not with her poker skills,
but with her acting skills.
(impact)
♪ eerie piano ♪
Chucky’s new main target is middle school
student Jake Wheeler, who purchased another
incarnation of the doll at a yard sale in
October.
I like to refer to this one as Cope-Chucky,
the same Chucky that Alice supposedly used
to cope with the massacre of her family.
In an attempt to make Jake more emotionally
distraught, Cope-Chucky kills Jake’s father,
then kills the aunt that took him in, Bree
Wheeler.
However, Jake still refuses to kill, but Chucky
realizes there may be another child who will:
Jake’s cousin, Junior.
Tiffany plays a part in driving Junior to
the brink of homicide.
One day, not long after buying the house,
Tiffany shows up at Bree’s wake.
She makes a big entrance, walks up smiling
to the grieving widower, and plants a kiss
on his lips.
Although her motive isn’t clear at the moment,
this is part of a larger effort to piss off
Junior, and turn him against his dad by making
him think his mother killed herself because
Logan was having an affair.
She continues to push this idea when she brings
over a meal for the mourning family, and Junior
comes to the door to receive it.
She tells him that it’s important to have
a woman in the house and plants the idea of
herself as the mother figure in Junior’s
life, which fires him up because he only just
lost his mom.
Tiffany pretends like she’s slipped up and
said too much before leaving.
This, in combination with Chucky hammering
it home later…
– Cancer wasn’t enough, huh?
You had to cheat on her too.
Real classy, Dad.
– …finally pushes Junior to kill his Dad
and completes Chucky’s Voodoo ritual.
This all ties into the part Jennifer Tilly
is supposed to play at the benefit screening.
That evening, Tiffany comes home and discovers
Nica-Chucky has gotten out of the chair and
finds her laying on the ground.
She assumes Nica is in control, unable to
get up due to her paralyzed legs, but this
assumption ends up being incorrect when she
receives a powerful kick, knocking her to the ground.
This is Chucky, and he straddles her with
a knife and threatens to kill her for the
fourth time.
Tiffany begs that he can’t kill her because
he still needs her, and she’s absolutely correct.
– Think about it.
– Thinking is for losers.
(Tiffany screams)
– [Chucky] Think again!
She’s right, bro.
We need her.
– It’s interesting how she’s developed
this animosity towards the Charles Lee Ray
living in Nica’s body, but when she sees
one inside a doll body, she lights up and
refers to him as Sweetface.
They’re the same person, it’s just that
she’s been spending a lot of time with the
one in Nica’s body, so their toxic relationship
has turned them against each other.
– F*** you Chucky!
– Thank you Chucky.
– This is also the example I brought up
earlier in this lesson; Chucky is a romantic
partner to her, but she treats him like a
baby.
– Come to mama! Who's a little Good Guy?
– It’s just weird man.
She takes Cope-Chucky downstairs to where
the army has awakened.
She also finds Jake’s friend Devon, who
is tied up, and Junior, who has joined the
side of the bad guys.
After Chucky gives a speech to his troops,
Tiffany sees to it that the army of Chuckys
are packed into the transport truck and stows
away the doll version of herself to facilitate
things, in case the plan gets off track.
She plans to meet the driver the following
day at the theater.
Back in the basement, it’s basically a party
for the bad guys.
She tries to talk to Cope-Chucky, who brushes
her off, as he’s busy catching up with Nica-Chucky.
She gets especially butthurt when Nica-Chucky
brags about being able to pick up women, even
in a woman’s body.
Tiffany mentions that girl on girl isn’t
the only thing Nica-Chucky is getting…
She’s talking about peni--
This causes Tiffany to blow up on Nica-Chucky
and slap him, which seems to knock Chucky
out of the driver’s seat and give control
back to Nica.
– At least she treats me with a little respect.
– Cope-Chucky senses what’s going on between
Nica and Tiffany and offers an apology for
his self-righteous attitude, but it comes
with a caveat.
– Kill her.
You know what that does to me.
– This leaves Tiffany flustered.
She argues that Nica holds a part of Chucky’s
soul as well, but he doesn’t care, since
there are 72 other Chuckys on the truck.
She reluctantly agrees, in tears.
– [Chucky] Who is it you’re afraid of losing Tiff?
Me or her?
– When Tiffany doesn’t act, he orders
Junior to do it, but before he can muster
the courage, Tiff retaliates by attacking
the doll and cutting his head off, which she
picks up and delivers another dramatic breakup
speech to.
Chucky threatens to kill her with one of his
many incarnations, but she boasts that he
needs her too much.
She brings out a suitcase, which she explains
to be a present from Glenda, the violent one
of her two twins.
The luggage is filled with bombs, which she
sets as a trap for Andy Barclay when he inevitably arrives.
(explosion)
Tiffany, Junior, and one of the 72 dolls that
Junior stole are loaded up in the car and
don’t emerge again until the next day, when
the mayor introduces Jennifer Tilly at the
benefit screening and auction.
During the announcement, the mayor’s youngest
daughter, Caroline, throws a fit because she
wants a Chucky doll, so Tiffany gives her
one extra.
– I’m sure one measly little sick
child can take care of himself.
Here sweetheart.
Your very own good guy doll!
– She doesn’t seem to stay for the screening,
which is odd because it’s the prequel to
a movie she was so moved by: Bride of Frankenstein.
I guess she’s got other things to do, like
meeting up with the driver and briefing him
on when the plane leaves and how she’s going
to kill him if he’s late.
With that she gets in her car and turns around
to see that Andy has hi-jacked the truck.
– Nooooooo!!!!
– Not all is lost though.
She must have forgotten about her backup plan,
or maybe the tantrum was just part of a performance
to get Andy to let his guard down before this
happens.
(glass shatters)
The doll version of Tiffany breaks the window
and introduces herself to Andy by holding
him at gunpoint and ordering him to drive
to the airport, if he knows what’s good for him.
Meanwhile, the human Tiffany goes back to
her favorite room at the Hotel Hackensack
with Nica, who was incapacitated.
It’s not clear how she snuck Nica’s unconscious
body upstairs without drawing suspicion, but
given that she’s a disposal expert, it’s
not hard to imagine she’d also be good at
smuggling live bodies.
She also had less weight to carry, because
as a preventative measure, she decided to
cut off all of Nica’s limbs.
This way Chucky can’t go anywhere no matter
what, can’t kick her, and kill her, as he
promised back at the basement.
(impact)
♪ rock music ♪
As Tiffany holds Andy at gunpoint, three Good
Guy Dolls from Chucky’s army escape from
their boxes and have their own conversation
in the back.
It seems that they don’t recognize Andy
and Tiffany right away, which Andy points out.
– They don’t know me.
They don’t know you either.
They don’t know
what you did.
– This distracts Tiffany, so Andy is able
to swerve, making her drop her gun.
He picks it up and blows her head off, and
that is the end of the Doll Tiffany introduced
in Cult.
That just leaves Tiffany living in Jennifer
Tilly’s body.
She isolates herself and Nica in the Beverly
Hills house, and decorates Nica’s room to
look like a doll’s room.
Tiffany’s obsession with dolls is projected
onto Nica and she treats her like a doll,
dressing her up, feeding her and mothering
her, despite Nica’s discomfort with this.
In addition to all of Tiffany’s other problems
she becomes, essentially, agoraphobic.
According to the Mayo Clinic, “Agoraphobia
involves fearing and avoiding places or situations
that might cause panic and feelings of being
trapped, helpless or embarrassed.”
It’s often described as the fear of going
outside, which may be a result of the authorities
closing in on Nica’s location.
She uses a security system app, allowing her
to monitor all points of entry onto the property
so she always knows who is coming and going.
Tiffany spends most of her time making Nica
watch Jennifer Tilly movies with her, like
when they watch Liar, Liar.
She repeats all of Jennifer’s lines as if
it was her who played that part.
She’s reveling in the past, just like the
character Norma Desmond from Sunset Blvd,
only she is obsessed with Jennifer’s past,
not her own.
Nica criticizes her for living this way and
points out that this lifestyle is not sustainable
in the long run, claiming, “I know you went
through all of Jennifer Tilly’s Simpsons
money.
How does one person go through one hundred
million dollars?”
Tiffany brushes this off saying, “It’s
not easy being me.
It’s not cheap being me either.”
However, her sense of safety is shattered
in November of 2022, when Tiffany wakes up
to find the doll version of her head under
the covers with her.
After feeding Nica breakfast, she pulls out
her nail file and cuts her own hand open,
and the sight of blood forces Nica to relinquish
control to Chucky.
Tiffany freaks out, and assumes Chucky is
responsible, to which Chucky responds that
he’s “coming for her.”
We still don’t really know how the doll
head got there, considering Nica-Chucky has
no way of communicating with the others, and
the multiple Chuckys are not a hive mind situation.
Perhaps if a new Chucky is created, he would
begin with all the information of past Chuckys,
and thus, know Nica-Chucky’s location.
However, we don’t know of any new Chuckys
being created between the movie theater incident
and the doll head wake up call.
Tiffany prepares for Glen and Glenda’s birthday
weekend.
The twins were born in March, not November,
but… they were busy!
They were in school!
Look, the birthday is just in November now,
OK?
To keep Nica quiet during the festivities,
Tiffany asks if she’d prefer the ball gag
or chloroform, but their conversation is interrupted.
Once again, her security system is breached
as a Detective rings the doorbell.
Tiffany meets Detective Gavin, who is investigating
the missing person(s) case of Nica Pierce.
Caught off guard, Tiffany tells him she knows
nothing and shuts the door on him, hoping
he’ll go away.
Which he does, but only temporarily.
The next day, Tiffany is preparing the birthday
cakes for them, when she hears the gate chime,
assumes it’s them, and allows access to
the house, but when she gets to the door,
it’s Detective Gavin again, insisting that
he thinks Jennifer Tilly is likely hiding
Nica Pierce.
In a panic, Tiffany slits his throat and with
no time to properly dispose of him, she jams
his body into a coat closet and tries to mop
up the blood with one of her sweaters, just
as Glen and Glenda walk in.
After so many years, and so much plotting,
she finds herself back in the familiar position
of trying to hide her violent true nature
from her kids.
They both seem shocked and surprised to see
blood, suggesting that maybe Glenda was too
young to remember witnessing Tiffany kill
the nanny on her fifth birthday.
Tiffany plays off the blood as just corn syrup,
explaining that violent content is what her
fans want.
This is enough to pacify Glen and Glenda.
As a reminder, they think that their mom is
the actress Jennifer Tilly, and don’t really
know who Tiffany Valentine is.
As they talk, the twins reveal that they know
their Mom is having money trouble, which makes
her defensive.
As she tries to change the subject, Glen asks
who Nica Pierce is, again, catching her by
surprise, as the twins are not supposed to
know anything about Nica.
Tiffany wavers back and forth between claiming
that Nica is someone she barely knows to saying
that she’s an obsessed stalker, which is
why she needs all of the security.
In the midst of this, Glen gets up to look
for a cell phone charger, and Glenda uses
the opportunity to ask if there’s anything
she’s hidden from them, because both of
them keep having the same nightmare.
Glenda describes this nightmare, which involved
lighting a woman on fire and a man addressing
someone named Sh** Face.
Tiffany, realizing that Glenda somehow remembers
killing Jennifer’s assistant in 2004, panics
and blames it on Glen and Glenda’s very
active imaginations.
To prevent them from finding the room Nica's
in, she hires a butler and even gives him
a fancy name, Jeeves!
Very original!
We have no clue where Tiffany found this guy
or what his deal is, but she puts him in charge
of guarding the door to Nica's room.
While she's leading him to his post, she's
startled to find Glen trying to get into the
same room!
Tiffany quickly shuts this down and tries
to play it off as if it's no big deal, claiming
that all of her shoes are in there!
As Tiffany walks back to the living room,
she is met with another surprise.
Literally.
– SURPRISE!
– Apparently, Glen and Glenda arranged their
own surprise party with Gina Gershon, Sutton
Stracke and Joe Pantoliano.
The whole situation turns into a huge intervention
of her friends wanting to know why Jennifer
disappeared on them for the past year, but
things get worse for Tiffany when Jennifer’s
sister, Meg Tilly arrives.
While everyone else had been ghosted for only
one year, Meg had been ghosted for twenty.
Tiffany does her best to brush the whole thing
off but Meg isn’t having it and pleads for
answers.
As Tiffany does a wardrobe change to look
more appropriate for a party, she puts on
the dress that the real life Jennifer Tilly
wore to the Academy Awards.
Little does Tiffany know, the whole party
was all a distraction so that Glen and Glenda
could help Nica escape.
Glenda slips some arsenic into Jeeves’ drink,
killing him, and leaving the door to Nica’s
room unguarded.
When Tiffany and the dinner guests discover
Jeeves’ body and the now empty bedroom,
Tiff acts fast and convinces everyone that
this is a murder mystery dinner party, and
that Jeeves is just acting.
This works to her advantage, because she too
needs to find out who killed Jeeves so that
she can use that person to find the missing
Nica.
As everyone investigates, Tiffany has two
separate bedroom encounters, one with Gina
Gershon and the other with Joe Pantoliano,
both of which serve to further distract her
from Nica’s escape, until Chucky regains
control of Nica’s body, and sneaks up on
her as she’s interrogating Meg, pulling a gun into her face.
– Ya know, I’m almost gonna miss you Tiff.
Almost!
(impact)
♪ dark soundscape ♪
– I think it’s fair to say by this point,
Chucky and Tiffany went from being a toxic
couple to being toxic exes.
The initial attraction that kept drawing them
back to each other does seem to genuinely
be gone, and now they are just trying to kill
each other.
However, to Chucky’s surprise, the gun is
empty, giving Tiffany the chance to slap Nica
in the face, which just like when Glen / Glenda
was a doll, forces Nica to switch back to
her true self.
As Nica awakens, she realizes this is her
last chance for escape and truly books it
out there using the prosthetic arms.
Glen and Glenda argue about leaving with Nica.
Glen is appalled that Glenda almost allowed
their Mom to be killed and opts to stay with
Tiffany, while Glenda takes off with Nica
to try to get the bottom of what’s really
going on.
Tiffany throws an absolute tantrum at the
thought of losing her beloved Nica, and tries
to close the gate before she can get away,
but Nica and Glenda make it through just in
time and are taken away by a very ADA compliant
van that’s waiting on the street.
Tiffany is left behind in a mess, and on top
of everything that just transpired, Glen asks
who Tiffany Valentine is, but their conversation
gets interrupted.
Gina and Sutton go home, thinking that they
just attended a really believable murder mystery
party, but Meg isn’t ready to give up and
stays overnight, confronting Tiffany the next
morning, and demanding a connection with her
sister.
When Tiffany asks when Meg plans on leaving,
she says she won’t leave until she gets
some answers.
Seeing that she’s backed into a trap, Tiffany
gets desperate.
She leaves the room and goes into what looks
like a storage room in her house.
She’s got a lot of secret rooms in this
house.
She pulls the cover off of a cage where the
real Jennifer Tilly, who is living in Tiffany’s
old doll form, is being held captive.
It probably would have made sense for her
to just hide Nica in here during the party.
You know, keep your prisoners all in one place.
Tiffany ignores her pleas for chocolate and
tells her that her sister is upstairs and
she needs to know who the Dean brothers are.
Jennifer realizes this could be her last chance
to see her sister or possibly escape, so instead
of telling about the Dean Brothers, she explains
the plot of the movie The Blues Brothers.
When Tiffany recounts this to Meg, she realizes
this and becomes even more suspicious.
Feeling embarrassed, she storms back to the
storage room, but this time she’s followed
by Meg and Glen who discover who this little
prisoner is.
Tiffany pulls out her classic nail file and
– gives everyone manicures.
No.
No that’s not what happens.
She brutally kills Meg in front of her long
lost sister.
That’s one way to put a damper on the family
reunion.
Glen, who has always been sheltered from Tiffany’s
evil side, watches in horror.
– Who are you?
– My name is Tiffany Valentine and I’m
your Goddamn Mother!
– As Tiffany sits down and explains everything
to Glen, she says she has one last birthday
present: the original Glen / Glenda doll.
They both vow that they need to go find Glenda.
Tiffany was once heralded as the body disposal
expert, but I guess she figured that hiding
the bodies sitting in her house wouldn’t
do much good, because police would probably
know that Detective Gavin’s last whereabouts
were at her mansion.
Jennifer Tilly was about to become a fugitive
no matter what.
That being said, I still don’t get why she
sets the house on fire.
It seems extremely unnecessary, but then again,
she’s not exactly a stable person.
She drives off in her red Pontiac with Jennifer
and Glen.
It doesn’t take long for word to hit the
news that the famous actress is a murderer,
but that doesn’t stop her from being swarmed
by fans at roadside diner.
I can’t tell if this is a dumb scene, or
some kind of scathing commentary on how people
idolize celebrities too much.
I don’t know why she didn’t just switch
back into the doll body at this point.
The only thing I can figure is that she kind
of knows that once she returns to being a
doll, Jennifer Tilly is going to be arrested,
so she’s savoring her final moments in a
human body that resembles her own.
She does plan to trade places with Jennifer
again, but Jennifer no longer wants her own
body now that she’s wanted for murder, so
she escapes the car and makes a run for it,
but her escape is cut short when she’s DESTROYED
by a semi truck, leaving Tiffany without a
plan B.
But first thing’s first, Tiffany and Glen’s
priority is getting back to Glenda, so they
continue the cross country road trip back
to where it all began: New Jersey.
Tiffany and Glen show up at the Catholic School
of the Incarnate Lord later that week and
discover all that has happened.
Chucky was separated from Nica’s body, and
Glenda informs Glen that their father is dead.
However, as we know, Chucky always comes back.
But we’ll get to that later.
Tiffany, somehow more of an emotional wreck
than usual, tries to talk to Nica, but Nica
pulls a gun on her, hungry for revenge for
everything Tiff has put her through.
Glen, being the more sheltered, non-violent
twin, dives in front of Tiffany to save her
and takes the bullet.
Tiffany and Glenda rush to the hospital, but
due to Jennifer Tilly being wanted for murder,
only Glenda can go inside.
Glen goes into a coma and is not expected
to live much longer, so on December 22nd,
2022, Tiffany devises a plan to sneak in and
transfer both twins back into the doll.
I don’t really understand why Glenda can’t
just do it.
I mean, Tiffany is just going off the Voodoo
for Dummies book anyway…
But I’m not an expert on Voodoo, there’s
probably a very good reason that this particular
soul transfer has to be performed by a 3rd
party.
The plan is nearly foiled when a police officer
discovers them, but a quick-thinking Tiffany
smashes him over the head with a vase.
Shortly after, Glenda’s murderous side comes
out.
(electricity flowing)
(man screams)
This allows Tiffany to execute the Voodoo
ritual and leave with Glen slash Glenda packed
safely in a suitcase, while the twins’ abandoned
human bodies lay in the hospital bed for this
unfortunate nurse to find.
(nurse screams)
Fun fact: these are not dead bodies, they’re
just abandoned vessels.
Which means I can show them!
I’ve been waiting my whole career for something
like this to happen.
Tiffany gives Glen slash Glenda a make over
and asks what she should call the unified
child now.
Everyone agrees that the name G/G would be
appropriate.
You got one G for Glen, you got the other
G for Glenda, it’s perfect.
Also G/G’s English accent comes back for
some reason, in addition to a sudden desire
to go to England.
Tiffany supports this, and offers a ride to
the post office, using the same method of
travel that she’s used for Chucky many times
in the past.
That just leaves the question of where she’ll
be depositing her own soul, and the answer
comes when she sees Hackensack’s former
Mayor live streaming her Christmas decorating.
We will just assume this is a burner phone,
because the police haven’t figured out her
location yet.
Mrs. Cross has a Wedding Belle doll, which
is exactly the type of doll that Tiffany needs
to return to doll form.
Realizing this is her one chance, she goes
to Michelle Cross’s house on Christmas Eve,
but to her surprise, the doll is missing from
the Nativity scene in the front yard when
she arrives.
She sneaks into the house and is immediately
discovered by Mrs. Cross, who, instead of
being alarmed by wanted killer Jennifer Tilly
being in her home, she is starstruck, and
tries to use her for social media clout.
This is cut short though when Chucky…
I told you he’d be back… lunges out with
a chainsaw and slices Michelle in half.
He’s about to go for Tiffany when Michelle’s
oldest daughter Lexy, drops down from the
stairs and pins him to the ground, while she
revs up his chainsaw.
Chucky pleads with Tiffany to help him, but
she demonstrates that she’s truly done with
him and walks away to go find the Belle doll.
She finds it in the younger sister Caroline’s
room, but quickly finds herself cornered by
Jake, Devon and Lexy.
However, just as the teenagers seem to have
her completely trapped, Caroline walks out
and hands Tiffany a knife, before basically
giving herself up as a hostage and explaining
that she’s been loyal to Chucky the whole
time.
She’s been brainwashed into believing that
her real family is not actually her real family,
and that Tiffany is actually her Mom.
Caroline has been waiting for the day that
Tiffany would come for her.
Tiffany, who loves an excuse to mother anything,
leaves with Caroline and flees to New York
City, where she changes her look to this Uma
Thurman kind of haircut and survives incognito
for a few weeks.
She seems to think she’s in the clear, until
late January 2023, when she gets a call from
Nica.
Nica first apologizes for nearly killing Glen,
but makes it clear that she’s still close
with G/G. Tiffany reacts to this in a way
that makes it seem likely that Nica probably
talks to G/G more than she does.
But before she can get too upset, Nica lets
her know that she knows where she is and is
going to kill her but allows her to get a
headstart.
Tiffany tries to do the Damballa ritual but,
like always, it doesn’t initially work.
– POSSESS! Possess! Possess, possess you stupid doll!!
– The doll does sit up but things don’t go
how Tiffany had planned.
This is no Belle doll at all, but rather Chucky
in disguise.
It becomes clear to Tiffany that Chucky and
Caroline have set her up.
Chucky lunges at her with his knife while
Tiffany screams helplessly on the floor.
That's the last we see of Tiffany Valentine... for now.
At the end of the season, it seems like Tiffany
may have finally met her demise at the hands
of Chucky.
This is something he's been attempting to
do for a few years now, and it looks like
he may have finally succeeded.
However, there's also the possibility that
Tiffany's Damballa ritual may have delayed
effects, as it has in the past, and she could
be transferred into Chucky - at the last minute.
This could force the two to share a body,
and could create some really interesting dynamics
in the future...
we'll have to keep watching, to find out!
So if you
want my updated analysis of Tiffany as new
seasons or movies are released, and if you
want to see my character timeline analysis’
of other Chucky franchise characters, make
sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring the deathbell and select
all notifications and I will see you in the
next one, assuming we both survive.
♪ dance music ♪